The falling stars you wished upon
are cinders now and now they're gone.
Their residue festoons my fetid field.
Revealing husks of lovers past,
their shells are all that ever last--
I've taken everything that they've concealed.
Whoever told you life was fair?
Look around you everywhere,
the cruelty of Nature is displayed.
Why the scorn? Why the surprise?
Everything that's born must die
and it isn't I who made the world that way.
What wicked little twist of fate
placed you here upon my plate?
Here where no one hears your cries?
Where was your God to steer you through?
Perhaps your God's forsaken you?
Otherwise, why lead you here to die?
I know the way how,
I'll melt away now.
I know the way.
I'm feeling bliss now,
dissolved to mist, how strangely I go away.
Now I finally know...
It's merely moments now,
moments now until your feeble flesh bends to my will--
and it will, so rest your weary head.
There'll be no pain, no pain at all,
as everything you are dissolves.
Your fate resolved upon my silky threads.
Now I finally now.
I know the way how,
I'll melt away now,
I know the way.
I'm feeling bliss now,
dissolved to mist, how strangely I go away.
Now I finally know...
I know the way how,
I'll melt away now,
I know the way.
I'm feeling bliss now,
dissolved to mist, how strangely I go away.
Now I finally know...